I want to play a super quick game with  you I want to know what you say no to in  a relationship are these some  deal-breakers okay so we'll start we'll  preface everything with he's perfect but  my name is no my sign is no my number is  no he's perfect but he always splits the  bill down the middle with you oh no he's  perfect but he has eight cats he's sad  no he insists you jog with him every  morning at 4 a.m.  no he loudly hums along to every song  but never sings the words huh Oh take it  he's good at humming no if you think Eve  he's not the no he does sing the lyrics  but they're always wrong it's like my  father can't figure it out  he's perfect but he's famous oh I don't  know yet oh cool yeah yeah Yulia eyes  immediately dahlias how are you not okay